hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast Breaking Bad with 3d to
develop
put screening platforms to interrogate
physiologically relevant models I am
Julie O'Rourke of leverage and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by lab roots comm
the leading social media site for
science professionals and sponsored by
PerkinElmer PerkinElmer is a global
leader focused on improving the health
and safety of people and the environment
their innovative detection imaging
informatics and service capabilities
combined with deep market knowledge and
expertise help customers gain greater
insight into their science before we
start there are a few instructions we
want to hear from you during this
interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment
answers are welcome to you can do this
by hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button on the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenter we are proud to
welcome model all nog PhD dr. Lal nog
serves as the head of the trans-nih RNA
AI facility at the National Center for
advancing translational sciences and
cats the facility is responsible for
developing and conducting genome-wide
physiologically relevant phenotypic
assays for intramural researchers she
joined in cats in 2013 or she worked as
a research scientist primarily to
develop an assay platform of 3d
physiologically relevant multi cell type
disease models that are amenable to
high-throughput screening for PhD in
molecular and cellular oncology is from
the George Washington University dr. log
nog has extensive experience in the
miniaturization and optimization
physiologically relevant cell based 2d
and 3d assays to make them amenable for
the screening of high-impact small
molecule and functional genomics
libraries her complete bio is found on
the lab routes website
I will now turn the presentation over to
dr. long nog thank you Judy
hello everyone I'm delighted to be able
to talk to you today about paradigm
shifts in the development of
high-throughput three-dimensional
oncology models from screening with a
view to enhancing productivity and drug
design as reported by the American
Cancer Society in 2017 1.6 million cases
of cancer are still reported every year
and more than 600,000 people will die
from this disease so this really
necessitates a paradigm shift in the way
that we think about not only the disease
but how we're going to mimic this in a
plate if the idea is to go from a plate
to a patient how do we best mimic the
disease innovate and to do this we have
to take a step back and think about what
we are really trying to model when you
talk about cancer not only do you have
multiple types of cancer and multiple
stages of cancer but you also have
within each stage whether you're looking
at a primary tumor or whether you're
looking at a metastatic disease and as
it would either extremely differently
and have to be treated almost as
separate diseases from the perspective
of screening models to be able to get to
an answer that would actually be
predictive and prognostic in him beings
so if you look at the difference between
primary tumors and that these
participants is location it's all about
the location of disease depending on
where the cancer is the athlete months
recapitulate that biology to be able to
give you a prognostic answer so if you
look at the primary tumor here that's
actually encapsulated by the basement
membrane this is designated as stage one
or two of any primary tumor however when
these cells are able to break the
integrity of the basement membrane extra
the fade and go all over the body to
establish these micro metastases if you
will this mess at metastatic disease
actually becomes a completely different
beast
has to be treated as such so imagine if
you will the Spotted plan and you think
about this as a primary tumor you can
use a pair of garden shears to actually
trim this plant and keep the
proliferation of the growth of it under
control but if you use that same pair of
garden shears and try to control the
growth of the sparse that would be a
gargantuan if not impossible task again
this goes back to talking about what are
you trying to model and how do you best
recapitulate that in an in situ plate
based environment so it all comes down
building to understanding your micro
environments what you have on the left
here are two ovarian cancer cells in the
milieu of its stromal micro environment
now what has been done a lot extensively
in spa has been to usually place cells
in two dimensional culture and try and
mimic this disease however that has been
pretty unsuccessful in getting drugs to
the market because what you're really
trying to mimic is models which mimic
the geometry of these three-dimensional
epithelial cells and how they interact
with the micro environment placing them
in a two dimensional format is does not
really serve that book so when it comes
to primary tumor models the most
frequently asked question as well whilst
y3d the answer to that is pretty
straightforward it turns out that human
beings are not two-dimensional so how do
we now tackle the question of what is
the best model to mimic in a fade so
that you can get better drugs to the
clinic faster for patients so with that
in mind and MCATs what we thought was we
would start off using developing these
three-dimensional models both for solid
tumors as well as metastases and then
feed them through a robotic system so
that you have a much higher success rate
of getting compounds into the clinic now
if you look at the left side of
the left panel on the slide you'll see
something that most of you are probably
familiar with two-dimensional polygenic
two-dimensional planet genic survival
assays on the left which are a gold
standard in the industry for getting any
sort of oncology compound into the
animal preclinical model but what ends
up happening is that there's a high
attrition rate of compounds that goes
into animal models leading to an even
higher attrition rate of compounds
getting into the clinic however if you
start off with a physiologically
relevant 3d model and are able to screen
thousands and hundreds and thousands of
small molecules and do functional
genetic screens in these models the
success rate of getting these compounds
into clinic is much much higher with a
shorter time to clinical trials as well
as a much less depletion on the
resources that are spent on all of these
studies in research lab so we've talked
about why 3d why we need to be models
because the next question is what is a
3d micro tissue and I don't think we as
a community have actually one answer to
this it really just depends on what
you're modeling so we have 3d tumors
here is something that I think many of
you are probably were very well aware of
you have 3d layers issues we are
actually trying to build some sort of
complexity into your system to mimic
what's going on in the body and then we
actually have 3d bioprinting of
architectural design tissues do to serve
as actual tissues and an actual
iterative model into which you can spin
your small molecules that have gone
through all of the the other 3d models
the idea really is to develop benchmark
and implement a series or a platform of
3d models that can then be much more
prognostic for a set of small molecules
that you sent into preclinical sense
with that in mind today I'd like to
first start with
focusing on three delia issues with the
particular case study that we have using
the human ovarian omentum this is a
project that was started in
collaboration to the University of
Chicago and it was the idea was to
benchmark this particular athlete and
make it much more prognostic for women
suffering from stage 3 and for ovarian
cancer and one of the first collections
of small molecules that was used to
develop this assay was what we called a
life collection here at the National
Center for advancing translational
Sciences we have over two thousand
compounds that have a diverse and
redundant mechanism of action runs
Bennett so there are several compounds
per target and this really allows us for
a target based enrichment analysis of
the responses that you get for da bomb
passing so given given that background
I'll give you a little bit about why we
choose to focus on ovarian cancer as I'm
sure many people are well aware ovarian
cancer is the leading cause of death and
gynecological malignancies worldwide the
earlier stages of ovarian cancer so if
you go back to the previous slides where
you look at the solid tumor when it's
stage 1 and 2 and it hasn't reached the
integrity of the basement membrane are
actually indistinguishable there are no
obvious symptoms however once it's
actually reached the integrity of the
basement membrane is when you have stage
3 and for high-grade serous ovarian
cancer which is usually associated with
a late diagnosis and an extremely dire
prognosis as you can see on the panel on
the left between 2005 and 2015 there
hasn't been a huge shift in either the
mortality or the morbidity associated
with ovarian cancer so it's really
necessities
again a huge change in the way that we
seek to understand the tumor and its
micro environment and this is going to
be extremely important for the
development of unconventional
therapeutic so we know now that ovarian
cancer is aggressive and rarely detected
at an early stage so there is a huge
unmet by the biological need to identify
small molecules that we can turn into
drugs to darkness metastatic disease the
objective of this particular treaty I
say that we collaborated on with the
people at the University of Chicago was
to identify inhibitors of ovarian cancer
cell adhesion to the site of metastasis
so imagine if you will the omentum the
ammmm is a fat fat that lies immediately
below the diaphragm in women and has
fiberglass material cells and adipocytes
what's important about the amendment to
remember the context of the assay is
that it is the first site for metastasis
in aggressive ovarian cancer so this I'm
telling you this so you can put into
context what how we model this in a
plate so in the plate on the left hand
side where you see the blue that's the
green and the red cells those are
actually patient cells the blue and the
red are and then you have this GFP
expressing cancer cell line that is that
we look for invasion through this matrix
the three-dimensional matrix which
actually represents the human Ament and
in a woman suffering from ovarian cancer
and on the right you have some enviable
data from some compounds that actually
came out of the screen in a mouse model
which is our preclinical model they're
actually going to show that the results
from a three-dimensional individual
screen were highly predictive for how
these these compounds would behave in an
animal model so the first thing that we
had to do was miniaturize the process
how do you actually recapitulate a human
omentum which has multiple cell types in
a plate so to do that we went through
many iterations of station sun lines and
as you can see one of the things that
you do with high throughput screening is
to look at please speed to please based
QC parameters and make sure that the Z
factors are all above point five which
essentially tells you that you have a
robust and reproducible assing now why
this is important in this particular
context is because we are actually
instead of using cell lines using
patient cells from multiple different
patients and not only do you have
multiple cell types you have multiple
patients that are represented so there
is a reasonable expectation that there
will be a certain amount of variability
in this passing and to our amazement and
surprise really this assay was extremely
robust and reproducible which really
speaks to the fact that once you get or
once you're able to develop a model that
accurately or to the best of our ability
mimics human disease the disease
mechanism comes into play and makes the
assay extremely robust and reproducible
so after having determined the plate
based to seat parameters we actually
optimize a biological control which you
can see on the right where you have to
machine and DMSO to attain actually very
effectively prevent the adhesion of
these cancer cells do the mental veil
once you wash this off you actually see
no cells of the doma team treated plate
wear as well whereas the DMSO which is
the non targeting control plate you
actually do see that these cells are not
only able to adhere to the fiber
blossomy to give yourselves but they're
able to migrate to the bottom of the
plate as you would see in metastatic
disease moving to worms in vivo
validation a lot of a small molecule
compounds that came out of the screen
brush we put into bound models of that
as the metastasis annotation against
various different cell lines and as you
can see all of these compounds reproduce
beautifully in a mouse model of
metastasis and patient furthermore
there's not only was it associated with
a decreased metastatic load but it was
sooo associated with an increase in to
mostly progression and overall survival
thereby going to show that once you can
we accurately target metastatic disease
you actually give in theory the patient
a much better chance of disease-free
progression moving forwards which for
this particular field is a huge leap
because the the one to five year
survival rate for women who present with
high-grade serous ovarian cancer is
actually very variable so any sort of
progression free survival that you can
afford to these patients is extremely
beneficial for this particular
population so screening campaign that we
undertook after the oncology directed
library of small molecules that we
talked about was a hundred thousand
compounds that comprised many different
libraries of central bonds we had some
in-house libraries we had some analog
that we were testing and what actually
came out of those was a cluster of
compounds that had differential effects
and these clusters actually grouped
together beautifully according to chemo
type and as you can see they were
various cutoff that we had for the
different clusters we wanted to look at
compounds that inhibit of metastases but
had no effect on cell viability because
those were the ones that we thought
would be great to use in conjunction or
in combination with with with standard
of care Kim and Eric critics for Barron
castle-like back with axial and
cisplatin to be able to prevent growth
of the primary tumor as well as
metastases in addition to that you also
have other clusters of chemo types that
prevented metastases as well as killed
ourselves and you know and this would be
in all-in-one drug so the idea was to be
able to separate all these various
different groups of compounds if you
will and then investigate them further
by doing medicinal chemistry and
developing different classes of drugs so
have having basically established then
that the athlete that would report on
metastasis as it were we had another
question well how do these cells really
metastasize to this to this metastatic
niche of the amendment
do they come a single cell do they come
as you know spheroids to become it
aggregates themselves that are that have
that are enriched for cancer like stem
cells so for that what we did was we
actually run proliferation assays on the
omental layer that we had established on
three dimensional mentally but have the
incoming cancer cells as either 2d or 3d
spiros and as you can see by the graph
by the bubble graphs on the left the
microenvironment really does matter it
does it makes a huge difference in terms
of what the the morphology of the
invading cell looks like and as you can
tell there there are certain classes of
compounds that prevent the proliferation
of the cell viability of these of the
metastatic niche when they're
proliferating as three-dimensional
steroids versus two-dimensional cells
which is not really realistic in the
inner in an enviable setting so if we
let us to a point where we could
identify compounds and targets that are
important interest on you as for
intercept intra as well as intercellular
communication in metastatic models
having established the small molecule
screen for this we put interested in
preserving the micro environment using
functional genomics approaches and to do
that what we did was we took the patient
fibroblasts epithelial layer and and
actually didn't as i already screamed
there well and where we actually in and
the data from here is from a micro RNA
screen that we did plot before we shot
the SI on a screen but the idea was to
see when you preserve the micro
environment by knocking down certain
genes in that system how does that
affect the metastasis of the cancer
cells through the system and as you can
see we actually got some fairly
interesting targets that we are not
following up on so the idea here was to
develop an MSA that could be used across
various functional platform to be able
to not only identify a chemical
modulator but also to identify
target that would potentially go along
with that modulator having established
that you have that we have this
metastatic model I wanted to talk to a
little bit about the initiative here I
do bioprinter issues that's being led by
dr. Paul Ferrar in conjunction with
organovo there are programs at the to
basically look at architectural
redefined
tissues and the idea is that this falls
into thought of these three-dimensional
three-dimensional layered platforms
where you can actually develop tissues
that will inform on whether your
three-dimensional the assays were
predictive and how far away in terms of
prediction and prognostic value the to
2d assays were from three-dimensional
and so to that point when we come back
talking about what is a 3d micro tissue
and how the bioprinted tissue serves as
a method to validate compounds are
coming are these model I'd like to draw
your attention to the three DS tumor
spheroid model because there's a lot
that that's out in the literature about
3d children spheroid models and we do
believe that it's a question of what is
your best fit for the biology that
you're studying are you going to will
get only single cells human spheroid are
you look at single cell and multi cell
types in the spirit to try and mimic the
stromal effect on the cancer cells do
you have to through inflammatory cells
into this system there's the size of a
spheroid matter these are all the
questions that we speak to learn answers
do in terms of developing screening
models and as you can see in them in the
next slide here what we really want to
be able to recapitulate is are really
the Baths of physiological gradients in
tumors and 3d tumor spheroid models so
if you look at the graphic on the right
you can see that there are decreasing
oxygen nutrient and pH gradients from
the blood vessel which is technically
with your drug of small molecules coming
from to the actual tissue where you have
the solid tumor model
now given the fact that these gradients
exist it's a reasonable expectation to
wonder well you know how much of my drug
actually gets to the tissue just how
many get cells this will kill along the
way to the gradients affect the potency
of the drug and as you can see on a on a
spheroid on the on the left hand side
there are actual zones within the
spheroid that may and may or may not
affect the potency of and the efficacy
of the drug in question so for really
what was most interesting is in terms of
investigating was the yellow quiet zone
because this is the zone that is
actually enriched in cancer stem like
cells which is which are responsible for
repopulating the tumor so when you
actually hit it - must be roid or a
tumor primary tumor with cytotoxic drugs
the first cells to go out the outer
rapidly proliferating layer and this is
usually what completely disintegrates
that you must however it's the the
yellow zone where these cells are not
that affected by the drug due to the
gradient that we already discussed but
they actually have the ability to
survive the cytotoxic insult and then
you Tate and morph into a different type
of cell that can then be populate a
genetically different tumor this is the
population of cells that we seek to
really eradicate through our 3d
screening model so to do that we've set
up a platform of cell based assays in
terms of increasing physiological
relevance the idea of this is to
investigate the effective target
perturbation on cancer cells in model
systems so you have a two-dimensional
layer something that everyone should be
familiar with and then you have a 3d
spheroid and a 3d organoid model in
terms of high content assays and high
throughput in high throughput screening
the 3d spheroid assays are those where
you have three rows from 30 to 50
microns and you have multiple steroids
for well in terms of what cancer biology
that's mimicking in
people what is really is mimicking is
the inability of the cells to attach to
plastic and and and the signaling
systems that are affected by this but
the three key organized models which
actually have one organized burwell
other real indicators of what is
happening to a drug or any sort of
genomic perturbation in the context of
pH gradient nutrient gradients and the
cell layers that you have women so we
went in in order to garner information
about the different stain 2d and 3d
systems we typically run all assays
against the three against the three high
troop assistants in increasing
physiological relevant and as you can
see here this is a snapshot of what of
what we hope will be useful to the
communities the idea here is really to
develop a blueprint if you will for each
compound in terms of what it does to the
endpoint which is which is viability but
also what it does morphologically and i
think the data on this slide will make
that point drive that point home a
little more clearly so if you look at
the two graphs on the left hand side we
have dose response curves porcelain
license and for rid of that in a model
of high-grade serous ovarian cancer and
as you can see they won't have very
similar ic50 extremely potent at causing
cell death however if you look at look
at the graphic on the right hand side
you can see that they actually have very
different effects on the morphology of
these organized even though the end
result is the same if you look at the
upper panel which is which are organized
treated personalize and even at the
highest concentrations you find of at
the highest concentrations you find that
the organ art is completely destroyed
however going to look at four end of
that and look at the morphological
effect at the highest concentration i
draw your attention to the bright field
pictures you'll find that the organelle
is still completely intact
again this goes back to our discussion
on the appearance of cancer like stem
cells within a tumor and how they are
able to repopulate a tumor which is a
genetic variant of its original type
what when they're actually exposed to
cytotoxic info having established a
platform where we can develop the
blueprints for these small molecule
compounds in a single cell type we then
moved on to see what the effect of
stromal cell would be on the cancer
cells and the reason to do this is to
build in the complexity while moving
towards a more relevant to be screening
model in cancer cells do not exist as
islands within the body they're heavily
entwined with the stromal counterparts
with the enzyme treatment part with the
endothelial counterpart to really to be
able to get it to reach and answer we
have to be able to build in a certain
degree of complexity that mirrors that
biology in in a human being but also not
to a point where the assay then does not
become robust and reproducible so that's
that's kind of the degree area and
screening where you have to make some
concessions in terms of how relevant you
can get so that you can actually get an
assay that is predictive so the first
thing that we did was in conjunction
with in Sphero we developed a multi cell
type to a model where we looked at hate
which is an ovarian cancer cell line
with and without dermal but within
without Psychopaths and on the left hand
side as you can see you have staining
for EGFR ki-67 collagen and as you can
tell from comparing the staining profile
when these cells are actually will with
fiberglass or their stromal component in
evil you have a much higher expression
of many of the proteins like collagen TI
67 and bpm what's remarkable so in these
multi selectable models is that there
seems to be some sort of tissue memory
or cellular memory
within each cell size because no matter
how you mix ourselves together the
epithelial cells will always form this
outer ring like cover around the
fibroblast of the stromal or the music
I'm on stem cell core and it seems to be
some memory of the way that the cells
associated with each other while they're
in separate culture when you actually
compare the maximum responses in terms
of drug responses but you can see on the
right between the homo and hetero two
big tissues you find a wide variation in
terms of not only what their responses
are but also how long it takes to
respond and typically what we find that
and this is actually pretty intuitive
typically what we find is that it's not
only a component of time but it is the
addition of these protective if you will
stromal cells to the cancer cells that
actually protect them or modulate their
response to a particular
chemotherapeutics have established that
multi cell Feb 2 mer models couldn't
could potentially give us more answers
about what targets are involved in chemo
therapeutic response and how you can
modulate that to actually get a
therapeutic window where you kill
epithelial cells and not the Shomo
components that you prevent systemic
toxicity we then took this athlete to an
RNAi eye screening platform where we
performed our Nia high throughput
screening of both single as well as
multi selection and spheroids because
the idea was to look at not only
morphology but also viability in two and
three dimensions so breast cancer this
is a comprehensive analysis of breast
and colorectal cancer in two and three D
and then we did the colorectal cancers
that are you with and without fiber
files and as you can see here on the
next slide we look at the difference
between breast cancer and colorectal
cancer in 2d and in 3d and you we
identified certain genetic targets that
are specific only to the GR
so these four things that were not
necessarily different between breast
colorectal cancer but they were
certainly different with respect to what
grew into D was treaty furthermore when
we then took this and did an analysis
between each cancer type so thin targets
that actually came up as positive for
just breast cancer or just colorectal
cancer as you can see in Figure C D and
E you can actually identify gene targets
that when knocked down would vary
reproducibly for the same differences in
phenotype between 2 and 3 D and some of
these g-dog is were actually the same
for both colorectal cancer as well as
breast cancer we then looked at the
protective effect of stromal component
of fiberglass in a color in a model of
colorectal cancer and as you can see in
panel a those are the scatter plots for
the viability readout for this and in in
B you actually see the immunostaining
off of 2d versus 3d single cell death
was multi-celled i've tumor model
wherein the knockdown of these specific
genes actually ends up giving us a
particular phenotype and we were able to
successfully identify and validate many
of these she targets as being
differentially regulated in colorectal
cancer in the presence and absence of
stromal fuzzball having established the
viability as well as a morphological
readout for colorectal and breast
cancers we then turned our attention to
the equivalent of the small molecule
screen for metastasis now this was an
assay that we actually developed for
breast cancer and the idea was just look
at migration in 2d which you can see on
the left and then invasion in 3d where
you actually have these
three-dimensional breast cancer
organized that
and fade into the individual and you're
looking for the doctor out of asylum
single certain genes that will actually
prevent this effect because those would
be directly implicated in metastasis of
the breast cancer cells and this project
is actually currently ongoing but the
idea is to use these acids to
interrogate or identify really
epigenetic targets of breast cancer
migration both from a gene silencing as
well as a small molecule perspective to
be able to die again a modulator to a
target and vice versa having established
the RNA I component the functional
genomic smartphone we then did we've
done a couple preliminary studies using
CRISPR derived cell lines to look at the
distance to look at the effect of
physiological relevance on targeted
chemotherapeutic so for this we use a
lung cancer model where we had we had
Christmas our minds that were targeting
the application and as you can see once
you have that genetic mutation goes into
the cell line using a three dimensional
organized system gives you a huge shift
in the responses which you would expect
to see in an in vivo system whereas in
the two dimensional system there's no
real change in the rate of the responses
shift so to actually make a even in in a
model where you have a genetic component
having a three-dimensional model really
gives you a sense of predicting further
on how good your chemotherapeutic is
going to be in terms of a diminishing
tumor size but be also giving you a
therapeutic pointer so with that with
that being said really what I'd like to
end with is the fact that
physiologically relevant given to big
asses such as those looking at three
dimensional systems does really create a
much much more relevant model system for
both darkus validation and drug
discovery
and both target validation and drug
discovery from a screening perspective
should really go hand in hand
because it really helps identify new
targets for existing drugs and then on
the flip side of it
deep involve the body pharmacology of
existing drugs for certain target
classes and the use of physiologically
relevant assay platforms and the
development of these assay technologies
such as those that we can do in three
dimensional multi well feeds is really
key to unlocking and preserving
biological systems one of the biggest
lessons I've learned from working with a
huge and multidisciplinary diverse team
is that translation truly is a team
sport
if there is no new man is an island no
scientist is an island and to be able to
really think about disease in this
context and
and accurately reproduce this in vitro
so as to have better better candidates
that enter clinical trials we truly do
have to work as a multidisciplinary team
to be able to put this dysfunction so
with that I will close and I'm having to
take any questions
excellent presentation dr. Lal nug
thanks for bringing that information to
us so before we get started with all of
your questions
here's a quick reminder about how to
reach us today questions can be sent via
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window get to as
many as we can first question is do you
see 3d models replacing animal models
that's an excellent question
Judy um I would have to say the idea
from a perspective of developing these
screening models is not to replace them
necessarily but to be able to be as
predictive because the idea is we can
screen hundreds and thousands of
compounds in these assays but you can't
do the same experiment in 100,000 mice
so if we can get to a point where we are
as predictive as an animal
that's all we really need to go into a
preclinical stage what are the minimum
requirements for a 3d model to be
relevant the best question we get a lot
because many different collaborators
many different academics are looking at
different aspects of biology so for
example if you looked at our breast
cancer migration it was really
sufficient to be able to put breast
cancer cells in Maitre job because
that's it's really sufficiency which
actually it's the stromal environment of
breast tissue and those four metastases
however if you if you go back to when we
were looking at the metastatic model for
ovarian serous carcinoma it gets much
much more complicated because you you
have multiple cell types in various
stages that you have in a mental layer
where you have B cell type 3 different
cell types and then you have an invading
cancer cell and they're all equally
important in altering the biological
question so I think when it comes to
three-dimensional models it really
really depends on the question that
you're asking if if you're asking about
their chemo therapeutic interactions and
protective the protective nature of a
stroma maybe just having two cell types
is enough but more and more with the
development of in regional oncology
therapeutics it is coming to our notice
that having an inflammatory component
which basically allows the cancer cells
to be protected from the Indian system
is also an important component in these
in these assays which has to be somehow
incorporated because if you want to go
to animal models and you have an immune
system and functional immune system in
the animal models you're not going to be
able to do an apples-to-apples
prediction if you're not sufficiently
recapitulating that in a
three-dimensional model so I really do
think that it depends the complexity
it's not a one-size-fits-all you don't
want to have all self ads for every TD
asking that you run I think it's the
minimum requirements for the biological
questions you're on time for a
particular thing how are we producing
are the results of assays in 3d system
um that's that's um surprisingly I know
I would have actually thought they would
be less reproducible then then we find
them to be and even when you talk about
as I mentioned with the with the assays
that we looked at for metastasis when we
were looking at cells from different
patients in every athlete's run the fact
that it was so reproducible in terms of
the target classes for compounds that it
was returning was actually incredibly
remarkable for us so the one thing I
will say about 20 systems is I think on
some level the biology takes over and
the biology is so robust
you know the biological question that
you're asking in a 3d system is is so
precise that these acids tend to be do
you be producible thank you if we didn't
get to your question we will follow up
with you via email I would like to once
again thank dr. Lowell nog for her
presentation do you have any final
comments um I would just say I think
well I'm a little biased here but I
think everybody should should consider
moving towards much more physiologically
relevant models because I do think from
an entire industry perspective we'll be
doing both academia as well as pharma
huge people thank you again
I'd also like to thank our sponsor
PerkinElmer for making it possible to
bring this presentation to you today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May 2018 you'll receive
an email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand and posted on lab
routes calm you're welcome to Ford this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast we'll see you next time